despite its name
nato is not simply a geographic alliance
it's a group of countries who stand
together because we believe in democracy
and the rule of law
the defense of human rights and the
values that underpin
all of our societies
that's why this
illegal brutal invasion
of a friendly democracy in ukraine
by vladimir putin is absolutely
unacceptable
and
nato and partners around the world are
united in condemning and standing up to
russia but also being there
to support the ukrainians as they stand
and fight for the values that underpin
all of our democracies
morning mr president
vladimir putin has already crossed the
red line into into barbarism and i think
it's now up to
nato to
consider
uh together the appalling crisis in
in ukraine the appalling suffering of
the people of ukraine
and to see what more we can do to help
the people of ukraine to to protect
themselves and see what more we can do
to
tighten the economic vice around the
putin regime and that's what we're going
to be
some of the things we're going to be
talking about
i think we have to double our efforts
putin cannot win this war this is very
important to
all of us to the security
of nato as well and the second thing we
need to discuss is
how to
increase our defense spending and how to
do it
very
wisely
nobody can feel safe now
maybe it will be
poland maybe it will be baltic states
but nobody in europe
even those countries which are distance
from from the uh direct border with
russia even those countries are not safe
today this is a challenge this is a
challenge for the entire region for
democratic world
western principles
maybe it will be the last challenge but
we cannot lose it
actually we are concerned when we see
that russian aggression forces are
shelling chemical plants
and similar facilities
this could trigger a disaster of large
scale
but i personally don't believe that
russian military itself will use
chemical or biological weapons
purposely for tactical
achievements because this would be
how to say
very unwise and shot in their own knee
oh